das ist unterhaltsamer fordert die
kosten auf youtube video und zocken
haben ein neues video hochgeladen leben
sie nintendos wünscht die ja erst
richtig gehört und ich als riesiger und
zocken verein hat mir halt gedacht okay
wir schauen uns das mal zusammen an
ich hab da sicher nicht bei lukas hier
liegen wir spielen heute auch apple in
ganz kurz ich heiße luca ca
mit lukas da gucken mal verkaufen können
oder vielleicht sogar noch ist also ich
lass das jetzt mal aus dem vorjahr
ziemlich die ganze zeit lukas nennen
aber okay die werden also heute
nintendos wii spielen und zwar just want
to switch spiel was max und ich auch
schon gespielt haben so willing kündigt
an dass die eventuell besser sind als
max und ich das wollen wir jetzt mal
sehen
[Musik]
haben die neues intro schauen oder bist
du eine andere musik machen die hand das
nach vielleicht gelingt es uns fällt
noch nicht platt roman ich bin das immer
so etwas machen es ist eigentlich besser
wenn ich das licht hier habe oder wenn
ich das licht einfach mal so aus mache
eigentlich schon bestens aus ist ne ich
feiere diese videos einfach immer so
kratz laden jetzt wirklich nicht häufig
was hoch sondern nur so alle paar tage
mal was aber wenn die was hochladen das
ist immer so gemacht aber okay wir
schauen jetzt mal das video weiter an
jetzt genau so hört sich ping kommen
aber jetzt sind wir an der stelle des
videos an gelangen wo die endlich mal
mit dem gameplay anfangen und sich mit
dem spiel wollte switch beschäftigen das
heißt das erste spiel was die jetzt
spielen werden wir tischtennis sein
mal schauen wie sich da so schlagen
werden bisher schlagen sie sich doch
nicht so gut und freunde jetzt kommen
wir zu einer stelle im video wo ich mir
wirklich als ich das gesehen habe
ich habe ich hab das angeschaut und
dachte mir nur so sind die betrunken
also ich weiß auch nicht die stelle
einfach selbst mal einig dass es mal
komplett unkommentiert jetzt durchlaufen
spielt mit dem blick auf eine hab ich
nur sagen also nicht nur dass ich nichts
verstanden habt ist auch wie spiel mit
der blinde kuh waren die reaktionen und
das lachen auf so eine aussage doch sehr
enormen also da hab ich da ein bisschen
gedacht okay sie haben die vielleicht
vorher irgendwie säckchen getrunken war
das nach einem weihnachts frühstück
osteressen oder irgendwie so weit aber
wir kommen jetzt erst mal zu den anderen
beiden senioren die natürlich mit einem
match sind und das ganze natürlich auch
richtig energiegeladen kommentieren auf
jeden fall klasse sie haben einfach so
weiter rufen und auf dem screen steht
schon längst vor lang in latein
tischtennis gespielt aber heute aber den
platten nicht mehr
hier wird uns gerade mitgeteilt dass die
rechte spielerin fünf jahre lang im
garten tischtennis gespielt hat ich war
auch mal tischtennis verein aber dass
das bringt einem tatsächlich nichts für
ottos wird wo man einfach nur schlagen
muss und das ist doch scheiß egal wohin
man schlägt man eine ganz kurze andere
frage
max und ich haben mario kart uns gekauft
also max krankhafter und ich und wir
hätten eventuell bock mal die tage in
mario kart video zu machen die da bock
drauf mit bestrafung oder irgendwie so
bei
[Musik]
treffen wir 40.000 jetzt nicht haben
hier haben wir wieder unser senioren
pärchen am start die zu beginn doch so
leicht angetrunken gewirkt aber man
werde auch gesagt die kälte kam so vor
insekten getrunken aber jetzt gerade das
das spiel einigermaßen gut das heißt wir
schauen uns mal an wie die partie jetzt
weitergeht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
vielleicht sind sie halt wirklich
betrunken ich meine wenn jetzt einfach
nur witzig findet wie sie sich gegenüber
sitzt und so macht dann ist ja alles
schön und gut aber in meinen augen ist
da sagt geflossen von erhoffen aber hey
es kann ja sein dass ich einfach nur
irgendwie szene gerade blut rausgepickt
oder so hier aus dem gameplay wir
schauen einfach ein bisschen weiter wie
es jetzt weitergeht dem match definitiv
da war da war definitiv sekt vorher am
set das match ist ja noch nicht vorbei
das heißt die beiden fangen sich jetzt
glaube ich erst mal kommen bis hin zur
ruhe und wir schauen uns das mal wie das
glorreiche champions-league-finale
tischtennis apple hingegen wie heißt
noch mal will hingegen uche mal schauen
wie es weitergeht
radefeld und warum lachen überhaupt oder
worüber lachen
eventuell kann uns dass der evelyn hier
in der nächsten aufnahme jetzt erklären
anscheinend haben sie es uns nicht
erklären
jetzt kommen aber auch schon zum
nächsten spiel was die senioren heute
spielen werden und zwar ist das
wettmelken das was max und ich schon
damals da bei switch wir halten jetzt
mal fest busche und häfen wurden gerade
gefragt ob sie schon mal eine kuh
gemolken haben und sagt ja schon mal
eine gute müssen dann lachen die wieder
los vielleicht gibt es dazu eine
erklärung die schafsbock ist los mit
diesem senioren gleich fragen wir
einfach mal die rutsche ob sie dahin
wieder einfach drauf weiß warum lachen
die beiden jetzt so schicken sie uns das
erklären kann mir nicht erklären
packe ich will nur mit euch lache man
aber jetzt stürzen wir uns auch mal
direkt ins gameplay reingeschaut darauf
dass bei den senioren funktioniert
entweder hat ja vorher gesagt dass sie
vielleicht besser ist sogar als ich bei
mir kommt
jetzt aber jetzt schon vier gruppen
strahlt jetzt geht er wenn du möchtest
besser werden als magst du nicht in
diesem spiel und max und ich sind auch
überhaupt nicht gut in diesem spiel aber
wenn du das ziel wirklich anstreben
willst solltest du die steuerung die
anschauen und sehen dass man so macht
aber hey leute ich werde jetzt überhaupt
nicht urteilen wir schauen uns einfach
mal jetzt das ergebnis an leib auffällig
hab verloren
es steht 0 einmal evelin klasse gemacht
aber wir haben ja heute nicht nur er
will in und uschi mit dabei sondern auch
noch die zwei anderen senioren und wir
schauen mal wie sich dann die helga
schlägt und vor allem wie das ganze hier
leidenschaftlich auch kommentiert wird
von den auf youtube da sitzen zwei
senioren vor der kamera und machen
produktion können wir einmal rüber
schalten zurück und evelyn was bei denen
so abgeht vielleicht haben sie sicher
wieder gefangen
also ist ja haben sie nicht ich bin eine
spielernatur ich bin mit meinen kindern
kinder mit meinen enkelkindern aber eben
brettspiele und kartenspiele
ja es ist aber so habe ich nicht ja das
ist ja das ist definitiv was realistisch
das ist definitiv was redest schöne
tasse kaffee dabei und dann geht er
trinkt man und hat dazu gehört die
unterhalten sich irgendwie über kaffee
mal wieder vorhin haben sie sich darüber
unterhalten welche türen welche
steinberger die schon geworden habe also
evelyn beyer ich freue mich gar nichts
mehr machen
der lukas ja ja ja das ist jetzt so weit
der gestimmt luca was könnt ihr drin
nein ich bin ich wie gemein sein ich
glaube ihr wisst alle dass das alles so
spaß und humor ist nicht willkommen
echte war noch viele kommentare von
wegen das sind senioren lacht wieder
nicht so aus ich lache mit denen ich bin
das doch selber verlustig und jeder hat
begriffen dass er will in das auch nicht
ernst gemeint hat weil sie hat einfach 0
und sie hat jedes spiel verloren also
ich glaube die ironie sollte man
erkennen fängst du uns denn ja sagen wir
mal welche war ja ja mit uns spielen
ihr seid klasse also vor
unterhaltungsfaktor ich habe noch nie so
gelacht bei einem youtube-video den
letzten wochen
das video war wirklich 1a ja wie gesagt
wir müssen einen ich will niemals
zusammenspiel beim fantreffen in bottrop
wird mir sogar vom volk vielen gesagt ey
kommt bald mal wieder mit den senioren
also e inhaber der kanäle des kanals
senioren sorgen schreibt mir doch mal
eine mail
und dann würde ich sagen
treffen uns mal ja ja das war es jetzt
der familie meine damen und herren wenn
solche gefallen hat wie gesagt lasst
like dabei 40.000 leicht werden wachsen
nicht mal mario kart switch video
hochladen findet jetzt hier oben ein
smiley eingeblendet darauf hier könnte
man kann kostenlos abonniert hast du
dich keine videos mehr darum will ich
auch meinen shop eingeblendet in dem
launischen am 16 also in zwei wochen
neue sommer produkte und hier unten ist
ein anderes video
[Applaus]